good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
here on the breakfast show on sky news
this thursday morning the chancellor
will set out new measures today to try
to ease the cost of living crisis as the
prime minister says it's time to move on
from partygate the long-awaited sugree
report was published yesterday and laid
bare the culture of downing street at
the time with details of partying
drinking and a lack of respect shown to
security and cleaning staff in just a
moment i'll be joined by the prime
minister's chief of staff that's steve
barclay and later in the show we'll hear
from labour's lisa nandi the shadow
leveling up secretary it is thursday the
26th of may
the party's over the prime minister says
it's time to move on from sugray's
partygate report but how long will his
mps back in
i'm at number 10 where boris johnson is
hoping to move on from the party gate
saga but can he today shift attention to
the cost of living
the chancellor will announce new
measures later to help households
struggling with soaring prices
further help is expected to tackle
spiraling energy bills i'm at a school
in southeast london to ask parents and
teachers if it'll go far enough
and i'm at the world economic forum in
davos as the chancellor prepares to
announce a windfall tax on the profits
of oil and gas companies
texas offers tears and prayers at a
vigil for the children of robb
elementary school but its political
leaders reject calls for gun control
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this why does
this only happen in your country
and a review into the deaths of arthur
labino hughes and star hobson find that
child protection in england needs to
change fundamentally
also coming up this morning wherever
you're watching us right around the
world
five months on from one of the worst uh
the world's first i should say forgive
me double hand transplant the airship
man learning to stroke his dog again and
hoping to get back to work very soon
[Music]
i will be speaking to the head of an
international charity it's a children's
charity and it's the head of the 10th
anniversary of their famed sierra leone
marathon
[Music]
hi everyone a very good morning to you
the chancellor is expected to set out
new support today to help tackle the
ever going ever growing cost of living
crisis but the prime minister's critics
have questioned the timing of the
announcement just a day after sue gray's
report into lockdown breaking parties in
downing street was published the full
report paints a damning picture
including parties past midnight a
culture of drinking and multiple
examples of what's described as a lack
of respect towards security and cleaning
staff
covered 19 was officially declared a
pandemic by the world health
organization on the 30th of june 2020.
england entered its first full lockdown
on the 23rd of march
between the 14th of may and the 23rd of
june widespread restrictions were still
in place
social gatherings indoors were banned
towards the end of this period people
were only permitted to meet outside in
groups of up to six people it was at
this time that four parties were held in
whitehall including one for mr johnson's
birthday in the cabinet room a full
lockdown returned on the 5th of november
2020 indoor household mixing was banned
and people were only allowed to meet
outdoors with a maximum of one person
from another household
during this time two parties were held
in whitehall including one where the
prime minister is pictured raising a
glass during a leaving party in downing
street
in the run-up to christmas four others
were held during this time london was in
tier four meaning people had to stay at
home and individuals could only meet one
person from another household in an
outdoor public space
2021 there were a further three parties
two later in april and one which was
held in downing street on the 14th of
january the country at that time was in
full lockdown
chief of staff steve barkley at downing
street is with us also an mp hi it's
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program this morning we all want to
believe that uh behind that famous black
door known probably the most famous
drawer in the world there are people who
have the utmost integrity instead there
were people drinking until they were
sick
a drunken brawl breaking out red wine
stains on the walls in downing street
laughing at cleaning staff who was
saying you know this is this is not
appropriate uh abusing security staff
what's your reaction well the prime
minister was appalled to read that when
he got that report that he himself
commissioned uh yesterday morning that
is why kaye has made such significant
changes and those changes are recognized
in the report
and it's also why he went personally to
apologize to staff yesterday because he
was so shocked by what he read yeah i'm
asking for your reaction too well
equally i was science i was sat with the
prime minister in his office when that
report came in that he had commissioned
and it came into his office at 10
o'clock and like him i was shot
particularly around what sue gray had
said in terms of the cleaning staff we
had an all-staff meeting yesterday in
downing street uh further to that it is
why we've had so many changes in terms
of both myself going into down the
street the permanent secretary a new
director of communication a new
principal private secretary it's why we
put procedures now in place but we were
appalled and that's why as i say the
prime minister apologized it's why he
went to the house of commons
and he said how humbled he was to read
about what had happened what were you
most shocked about uh i think what uh
the disrespect to to staff within the
building i think that was
for someone for me you know growing up
in lancashire
coming from a background that i do i was
particularly shocked to read that
and he's
apologized personally to all of the
staff that were affected he went and
apologized to to staffordshire the shift
voters so it's a question of which staff
were in the building yesterday but he's
going to seek out the cleaning staff he
has gone out to seek out stuff to do
that he came to to the house as well in
terms of colleagues and it's why he's
made so many changes uh in response and
and sue gray recognizes those changes in
the report and say those should now be
able to bed down why did he tell
parliament on the 8th of december that
no rules were broken
because as he said in his statement he
was working he was going for a very
short period of time
two events in his work capacity and
indeed that has been reflected k in the
response from the met police now clearly
long after he had gone their incidents
as you say at the top of this item in
terms of their behavior um but this was
those things that happened when
sometimes he wasn't even in the building
he was at checkers or long after he had
left but he did attend eight of the
sixteen parties that sue grey has events
that sue grey was talking about he also
said he felt a duty to say goodbye to
colleagues
um
so he could say goodbye to a work
colleague
but
people watching this program this
morning couldn't say goodbye to a dying
relative yes and i've seen that in terms
of commentary and i think all of us i
know as a you said at the start as a
constituency mp i know for my own
families in the constituency that that
was heartbreaking for people that
weren't able
to say goodbye i think it was probably
the worst feature one of the worst
features of the pandemic that people
didn't get that moment of being able to
say goodbye i think as was covered at
the time in in the rules people working
in downing street because of the nature
of their jobs working for the prime
minister were there working on our
vaccine were allowed ensuring we had the
ppe working very long hours in tight
knit
situations and there was a work
exemption for them to be able to work
together and it was in that context that
the prime minister was very briefly just
for usually for a matter of minutes why
would he feel many people why would he
feel that he could say goodbye to a work
colleague but people couldn't go to a
graveside because they were already in
the building they were already working
in tight-knit groups they were already
there bottles of wine two bottles of
champagne and a bottle of gin on the
table what sort of workplace is that
well as i say you know these were very
the metters looked at these issues these
were very brief periods of time prime
ministers the nature of a primary
serious job is to go from meeting to
meeting to meeting that is the nature of
their job but at the same time he has
recognized the need for changes he's
made those changes and sue grey herself
has recognized there's been significant
change with a permanent secretary with a
change of leadership team
as a result of the lessons we've learned
meeting names changed people advised to
dodge photographers one special adviser
saying our drinks which we seem to have
got away with i mean it was it was a
culture of rule breaking and he is the
chief exec if you will he was presiding
over it all well i think there is a
difference and i think people recognize
between prime ministers going from
meetings to meetings in the course of a
working day
and people who late at night long after
he has gone where behaviors clearly
clearly were inappropriate and that's
why he himself you know i was sat with
him yesterday when the report came in
after 10 o'clock
and he was shocked by that and that's
why he gave the apology let me read
exactly what the number 10 special
adviser texted uh martin reynolds about
the 20th of may event just to flag that
the press conference which we were all
watching will probably be finishing
around that time so helpful if people
can be mindful of that as speakers and
cameras are leaving not walking around
waving bottles of wine etc you're
telling me that the prime minister
didn't know about any of that but in
front of us i wouldn't have seen those
sort of emails and messages
and martin reynolds wanted brought it to
his attention even though it was his job
the prime minister's in the course of
his day working very long hours i mean
some of these incidents okay happened
when he wasn't even there he was a but
somehow so there's a question and and he
addressed that in his statement to the
house of commons that going to something
for a matter of minutes to thank people
as part of his role as prime minister is
very different to the very shocking
things quite rightly you're highlighting
okay they are shocking i was shocked to
read them yesterday but they're
different to things that were done in
his prime ministerial capacity so you're
basically doing the job that martin
reynolds had done previously if this
sort of stuff had come to light for you
would you have brought it to the
attention of the prime minister well i
actually my role is different we also
have a new principal private secretary
but it's part of a wider team so the
whole team but would you if you'd known
this would you have brought it to them
well i would hope so but obviously it's
difficult to second guess the very
intense working conditions i wasn't in
downing street at the time so it would
be difficult for me to second-guess the
pressures the intensity of the things
that people
were going through at that time i was
working in the treasury uh my role was
in a different way but we've reckoned
this happening at the treasury no it
wasn't did you know well because i was
working in the treasury the treasury is
a very different building and i think
one of the the challenges actually for
people working in daniel street is just
to lay out the nature of the building
very very small rooms the treasure
actually is a very different composition
so and more people were able to work at
home so just the structures between the
two yeah but if it was okay so let me
put it this way then if it was happening
in downing street now you wouldn't know
because of the way the building's set up
no the point is you would know because
there's lots of small rooms and it's a
it's a house in essence and therefore
people are much closer together the the
two are just different workers okay
you've been an mp since
2010 was it your understanding that um
david cameron would have overseen wine
time friday i don't know i mean i was i
was about mentioned p at the time so i
wasn't working down the street and she
wasn't close to raising maybe because
you weren't you were a brexit secretary
weren't you would you have seen uh one
time fridays when she was in dining
street well again i wasn't working that
you're referring to the press office i
wasn't working uh in the preference i
was actually again working in number
nine at downing street so it's just
simply about where if you're asking to
my own personality
i was working in number nine i think
they would have been happy with what was
happening in down the street well i
don't know i mean you're asking me to
she was and she wouldn't have been at
all happy you know sitting with the
prime minister yesterday he was shocked
and particularly as i say around
the treatment of some by some staff
of others uh in the building and and
that is something the prime minister was
not aware of he was shot by it is why
he's made the significant changes uh and
his is more than why the lessons are
learned and indeed that's why he said he
was so humbled yesterday when he
discovered those sort of incidents said
he should accept and bear ultimate
responsibility well he did he went to
the house of commons and he said that he
gave an apology
he accepted that he is ultimately
responsible he explained
his role as prime minister
and people were working incredibly
intensively within danu street during
that time it was an extremely
challenging time but at the same time
it's clear mistakes were made and that's
why
following the interim report the prime
minister changed the senior team and
took on board the comments she made does
the pm have honor
yes he does
does he tell lies no he doesn't he's
been stacked twice for lying well
you know yes my opinion i work very
closely with him he is focused on our
response to russia ukraine he's focused
on the huge challenge economically for
families for your viewers in terms of
the cost of energy the cost of food he's
getting on with the job he got the big
calls right including during kobe the
fastest rollout last year we had the
fastest growing economy in the g7 uh on
russia ukraine he has led and i want to
continue to have earlier
responsibilities
he has been getting the big calls right
but he accepted in terms of some of
these incidents that there were lessons
to be learned okay martin reynolds is
still working for the government um he's
reportedly being lined up for an
ambassador's job allegra stratton
was expected to fall on her sword
you're a modern politician and are you
content with those two scenarios well
it's not appropriate and it never has
been under successive administrations
for ministers start commenting on
individual sort of hr matters obviously
sue gray has addressed some of those
points particularly around
more junior staff versus senior staff
but these will be for the civil service
to take forward in terms of that i
understand that allegra stratton was a
broken woman we saw her outside her
house absolutely bereft by what had
happened and yet the man who was you
know ultimately her boss i suppose um he
looks so he might be an ambassador in
saudi arabia well the point is most of
the people named in this report have
actually left the civil service in terms
of one or two individuals that are still
there as i say okay i don't think it's
appropriate as a minister to start
speculating so let me ask you duty were
you were you content with the way
allegra stratton was treated
well i wasn't at number 10
that doesn't matter well it's very
difficult for me to know exactly what
happened at that time i wasn't there
what i can say having worked with
allegra at the treasury is just how
highly respected allegra was at the
treasury and still is from ministers and
certainly colleagues that worked with
her there we believe that the moving on
to the windfall tax we believe that that
is definitely uh going to go ahead
that's uh what um our tamara has told us
this morning and basically she knows
everything so let's just say that it is
we can agree on and tomorrow there we go
there we go so she says it is going
ahead uh this is what the chancellor
told the commons on the third of
february this year of course winfield
tax sounds superficially appealing but
we on the government benches deal with
complex problems in a responsible way
here's the rob the obvious impact of a
windfall tax would be to deter
investment it is as simple as that why's
he changed his mind well he's right that
what labour were proposing in terms of
their winful tax would have deterred
investment and we've just brought out
our energy strategy and a key part of
that is how we interact inward
investment indeed as a key part of
responding to the cost of living and
having a long-term energy strategy what
we've said k throughout is we need to do
two things firstly recognize that there
is a huge pressure coming for families
in terms of energy costs and food costs
actually there's a huge pressure now but
we can see coming to the autumn that
that is going to to get worse so we need
to be in a position to have targeted
support to those families but then in
terms of paying for that as we look at
the balance between how much he's done
through debt and how much he's done
through revenue raising we need to do
that in a way that doesn't deter
investment and having worked with the
chancellor throughout the pandemic what
i know he's he's across the detail
incredibly diligent and looks at getting
that balance right in a way that the
windfall tax proposed
by the labour party simply would have
deterred the inward investment that
would have cut across our energy
strategy which part of lancaster are you
from london live oh posh [ __ ] live in
the center is very push uh what do you
think the good people of lithuan would
think this morning about the timing of
this announcement
uh in what way uh the fact that it's the
day after the sugree report well no i
think it's uh because we've had the
off-gem uh guidance or firstly on the
sue gravy report we don't control the
timing of that k i mean that's the
timing i don't know so so so in terms of
the timing of that firstly we don't
control the timing of the supreme report
and indeed the timing got that is shaped
by the met police
investigation what we've always said is
in terms of the fiscal response we
wanted to see from the afghan guidance
what the full
impact would be
in the autumn of families so that we can
get the design of that package right so
it's absolutely logical we've had that
guidance this week from ofgem that is
why uh the chancellor's coming forward
today it's also in terms of parliament
and parliamentary timetable uh
parliament will be off next week for the
jubilee so it's logical before
parliament goes into a recess on the
back of the off gem guidance this week
that we then bring forward this
statement we obviously don't control the
timing of the system are the
sand dunes still is lovely in them
they're fantastic isn't it beautiful
part of the world thanks very much for
joining us much appreciated thank you uh
let's have a look at what's happening as
far as the papers are concerned this
morning the metro has the headline we
got away with it paraphrasing the words
of a former senior downing street
official in a message to a colleague at
the time of the parties
the i quotes from the report describing
a failure of leadership in number 10 and
across whitehall
the guardian mentions the drinking
fights and vomiting that allegedly took
place at the gatherings
the male says what many conservative
supporters believe that boris johnson
feels he has been vindicated the
headline is is that it
similar sentiments in the express really
is this what all the fuss is about
but as you might expect the morris take
on is it that boris johnson is just
laughing at us all
the government's insistence that it's
time to move on from the matter is
reflected in the telegraph with the
chancellor poised to announce additional
help for energy customers
and finally the time says the chancellor
will announce that every household in
britain is to get hundreds of pounds to
help them cope with the cost of living
still to come on the programme for you
this morning we'll hear from the chair
of the house of commons committee on
standards that's chris bryant as he
gives his reaction to sue gray's full
report
just after eight we'll get labor's
reaction with the shadow leveling up
secretary lisa nundy
and then we'll discuss where the prime
minister goes from here with his former
press secretary that's will walton
[Music]
in the wake of sue graves report the
government is this morning looking to
refocus with the chancellor expected to
announce a windfall tax on energy
companies in a bid to ease the cost of
living crisis
um well johnny is now from tidemill
academy in southeast london is ivor and
paul is standing by at the world
economic forum in davos for his paul to
you first of all if i may a windfall tax
uh yes something as you've just been
putting uh to the government's
representative this morning the gov the
chancellor said he opposed most of the
ministers in charge have said they've
opposed including the business secretary
but now it is coming it's effectively a
retrospective tax on the enormous
profits that oil and gas companies have
been making as energy prices have spiked
around 8 billion
pounds bp reported this year how much
will it raise well remember the
government's already making uh more
money because
those companies are making higher
profits through taxes another 10 on the
40 tax they pay on profits estimates
between 1.2 to 2 billion pounds a year
would be generated that's a lot of money
but it is a drop in the ocean with the
scale of tackling the cost of living
crisis and rising energy bills if you
spread that two billion pounds across
every energy bill it would be 60 pounds
per household well prices have already
gone up 700 pounds another 800 pounds is
in the post if you wanted to raise
benefits for everyone on benefits and
pensioners that's gonna cost nine
billion pounds so the windfall tax is
not an answer to the cost of living
crisis it's merely a way of paying for
part of it the wider context of this
cost of living crisis is something
that's been discussed here day after day
at the world economic forum and it is
some of the things that the government
can't do anything about there's global
inflationary pressures driven by those
rising in energy prices and of course
all of that
exacerbated by the war in ukraine that
is
causing a russian the russian gas issue
is causing an energy crisis and there's
a food crisis on the horizon whatever
the government does today will be of
some short-term relief we can't
guarantee they won't need to do more
i've just spoken to the director general
of the word trade organization and she
said we are in for a rough time in the
short to medium term
so consumers may get some relief today
but it might not be the last the
government has to provide okay and uh
either
any money is welcome but as we're just
hearing there from paul um a couple of
hundred quid is not going to cut it
we'll have to wait and see
what the details are
yeah exactly that's right kate i mean if
you want an illustration of just how
severe this cost of living crisis is
have a look behind me over my shoulder
is a food bank in a school there's a
tins of baked beans packets of cereal
here that the school has set up to help
hard up families parents can help
themselves if they're struggling to put
food on the table that's how hard things
are for some people but help as you say
could be on the way with the chancellor
set to announce this cut to energy bills
the 200 pound loan off our bills um in
october is set to be increased
potentially to 400 pounds and it may be
made into a grant so you don't have to
repay it other potential measures
include potentially a one-off payment to
vulnerable families an expansion to the
warm homes discount potentially a vat
cut on fuel but to talk more about this
is um marian drake the head teacher here
at tide mill academy um marion
this food bank in a school that is
really serious isn't it it is it is we
set it up because we noticed a sharp
increase in a number of families coming
to us for food vouchers so we set up a
small food bank and a community footage
and it's been tremendously appreciated
and really well used just quickly then
is is 400 pounds off your energy bill
really going to make that much of a
difference i think it's a start but for
lots of our children our free breakfast
and free lunch are the only meals they
get in the day so i think it's a start
but when things like this are needed in
schools more perhaps needs to be done
all right thanks marion we will be
speaking to parents as they arrive to
drop off their children and any help
clearly
is really really needed
either and uh paul thank you both very
much indeed for the update thank you
they both got the memo about the coach
this morning didn't they now a prayer
vigil has been held in uvalde in texas
for the 19 children and two teachers
shot dead at robb elementary school
texas governor greg abbott and senator
ted cruz were among those who attended
offering support and sympathy to the
community but digging in against calls
for gun control our us correspondent
mark stone reports from texas
as the sun went down in this small texan
town the community came together in
their hundreds
[Music]
a moment for prayer
to reflect on the unimaginable
beyond the hugs though how can anyone
explain to dads like stephen garcia why
his daughter ellie is gone
[Music]
there are private moments of grief all
over
so often places like this are said to be
tight-knit but you can feel it here
so many know someone now in so much pain
and yet even here even after something
like this the political divide over guns
is so stark the governor of texas and
his ally in the senate the men who block
all attempts to change gun laws they are
here and not unwelcome there are 19 sets
of parents
who are never going to get to kiss
their child good night
again
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue i i get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go the proposals
from democrats in the media
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two
ar-15s if you want to stop
violent crime
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this why does
this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's
honestly god love you senator it's not i
just want to understand why you do not
think that guns are the problem why is
this just an american problem
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
mass shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why is it
that people come from all over the world
to america because it's the freest most
prosperous safest
if that wasn't clear enough the
governor's earlier news conference
struck the heart of this gulf in
american society
the republican leader of this state
clashing with his democratic rival no
common ground no compromise
and so they left the vigil in their town
that will now be remembered for just one
thing
until the next one
mark stone sky news in texas
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you now and seven new
cases of monkey pox have been identified
in england bringing the total number of
reported infections in the uk to 78.
there's been one confirmed case in
scotland but non-reported in wales or
northern ireland despite the rising
cases the uk health secretary and the
security agency says risk to the uk
population remains low
campaigners awarding guidance for rape
trial prosecutors could dramatically
reduce protection and rights to privacy
for victims and turn them away from
vital therapy the end violence against
women coalition rape crisis england and
wales and the center for women's justice
says that crime prosecution service
advice would increase the likelihood
that rape victims private therapy notes
will be accessed by prosecutors and used
to discredit them in court
police have seized thousands of weapons
and made nearly 2 000 arrests as part of
a crackdown on knife crime
officers say that razor blades fixed to
toothbrushes hunting knives and machetes
were among the weapons confiscated
during operation scepter in november
students in shanghai are to return to
the classroom as china begins to ease
kovid lockdown rules junior and senior
high school pupils will be allowed back
to school from the 6th of june followed
by a week later by final year middle
school students other years will
continue online classes for the rest of
the term as part of a staggered return
to normal life
to the war in ukraine now
and president zielenski has strongly
condemned suggestions that ukraine
should give up control of its territory
that is occupied by russian forces he
compared those who argue for giving
russia a piece of ukraine to those who
ceded territory to germany in 1938 in
the hopes of preventing world war ii
and the world bank has warned that the
war in ukraine could trigger a global
recession world bank president that's
david malpass said that higher food and
energy prices would stunt growth and
that some countries including germany
have already seen their economy slow
down
the timings for the platinum jubilee
weekend have been unveiled with the
celebrations just over a week away
here's some of the highlights of what
will happen as the nation pays tribute
to the queen's 70 years as sovereign
on thursday the queen's birthday parade
trooping the colour begins and at half
past 10 it's hoped that the queen will
make an appearance on the balcony to
watch a special fly past friday the
royal family will attend a service of
thanksgiving at saint paul's cathedral
followed by a guildhall reception hosted
by the lord mayor
on saturday the queen and her family are
expected to head to the races at derby
day of course where the monarch is due
to be greeted with a guard of honour
made up of 40 of her past and present
jockeys and then on sunday the jubilee
pageant takes place in central london
with a three kilometer carnival
procession moving down the mall and past
the palace
and from thursday next week we'll have
full coverage of all the jubilee
festivities joined by our royal
commentator alastair bruce and the one
and only joanna lumley
good look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
we're in for another unsettled day but
things should settle down tomorrow
mainly mild and breezy now with cloud
and rain across central parts but
northern scotland is quite chilly with
showers
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a man whose hands were left unusable uh
a debilitating condition uh he's been
given a new lease of life after what's
believed to be the world's first double
hand transplant 48 year old stephen
gallagher from airship was diagnosed
with an autoimmune disease that causes
scarring of the skin and internal organs
caused his fingers to start curling in
until they were in a fist position
so he underwent a 12-hour operation last
december after a suitable donor was
found he hopes to return to some form of
work once his hands have improved
enough he says the thing that he's
enjoying most
is being able to stroke his dog again
now the male has a picture of dame
deborah james who attended the chelsea
flower show on tuesday evening the
podcaster who's recently revealed that
she sadly is uh suffering from
receiving end of life care was said she
was honored to find out that someone had
named a rose after her that's lovely
isn't it time shows the ethiopian circus
troupe circus abyssinia practicing their
acrobatic routines ahead of their show
at the underbelly festival at london's
earl's court their routine will include
acrobatics contortion and fire juggling
finally the guardian brings us a picture
of french tightrope walker nathan paulin
setting a world record by walking 1.4
miles across france's across france i
should say to mal sir michelle so from
i'm guessing the mainland over to
monster michelle
lovely
uh top stories for you this morning the
prime minister is facing a fight to keep
his mps on side after sugray's scathing
report into lockdown parties in downing
street
chancellor will announce new measures
later to help households struggling with
the cost of living crisis
and a prayer vigil has been held in
uvalde in texas for the 19 children and
two teachers shot dead at robb
elementary school
[Music]
in the last half an hour danu street
chief of staff has told this program he
is shocked at the revelation staff in
number 10 were rude to cleaning and
security personnel during lockdown
parties
steve barkley also told me the prime
minister is personally apologizing to
those affected in the wake of sue grey's
report
i was sat with the prime minister in his
office when that report came in that he
had commissioned and it came into his
office at ten o'clock and like him i was
shot particularly around what sue gray
had said in terms of the cleaning staff
we had an all-staff meeting yesterday in
downing street uh further to that it is
why we've had so many changes in terms
of both myself going into down the
street the permanent secretary a new
director of communication and new
principal private secretary it's why we
put procedures now in place but we were
appalled and that's why as i say the
prime minister uh apologized is why he
went to the house of commons
and he said how humbled he was to read
about what had happened what were you
most shocked about uh i think what uh
the disrespect to to staff within the
building i think that was
for someone for me you know growing up
in lancashire um coming from a
background that i do i was particularly
shocked to read that um and he
apologized personally to all of the
staff that were affected he went and
apologized to to staffordshire the shift
voters so it's a question of which staff
were in the building yesterday but he's
going to seek out the cleaning staff he
has gone out to seek out stuff to do
that he came to to the house as well in
terms of colleagues and it's why he's
made so many changes uh in response and
and sue gray recognizes those changes in
the report and say those should now be
able to bend down
tomorrow's downing street for us this
morning hi tamara thoughts good morning
morning kay well steve barkley is one of
the many new people in charge in downing
street and he says that that shows how
much the culture has changed since the
dark days detailed in sue grey's report
and very much the tone of what the prime
minister said yesterday and steve
barkley said today is while the prime
minister is very sorry about what
happened and he said he's humbled he's
learned lessons from it although the
reports show that he attended eight of
the sixteen gatherings that sue grey
investigated so he must have had a sense
of what the culture was like in downing
street the worst excesses of the
drinking fighting writing emails saying
i think we've got away with it were not
linked directly to him there was no
smoking gun leading to the prime
minister that we didn't previously know
about just a sense that he was at the
helm of an organization of a downing
street in which people were routinely
breaking the rules and for that he said
he has learned lessons and now hopes to
move on so what do we take from this
report that we waited six months for can
he move on well in number 10 they're
talking about it being a tough day
indeed a tough few months they
particularly focus on how appalled the
prime minister was by the revelations
which they say he had no idea about
about rudeness to security and cleaning
staff and it's i've been told today that
he apologized to some of those security
staff last night and will apologize to
some of the cleaners today when they
come on shift does this move the dial
though so immediately it doesn't look
like for tory mps who are of course the
most important voters the prime minister
has to care about right now anything is
shifting imminently like today or next
week but certainly if the prime minister
is not able to get things back on track
and he's going to try to do so today
we're expecting a very substantial
package to help people with the cost of
living they conservative mps some of
whom i spoke to last night including
some of those very loyal to the prime
minister know that he and they have been
damaged by this episode and if
that damage cannot be healed over the
coming months which will involve some
very difficult choices for families and
for the government in terms of how much
it spends to help people then he may not
be out of danger yet okay thank you
well let's get more reaction to the
partygate report now should we chris
bryant labour mp and chair of the house
of commons committee on standards joins
us as you can see hi chris thanks very
much for joining us on the programme
good morning this morning uh we're
moving on now says the government uh
they need to start to help people more
with the cost of living crisis that's
exactly what they're going to do
well they certainly should be doing that
because if you look at the average
family in the room though my my
constitution said that they've lost 2
500 pounds
a year and there's they can't see any
means of making that up and that's the
you know universal credit being cut and
the significant increase in cost of
living and but just to go back to the
events of yesterday steve barkley just
said that everything's changed at downey
street well the one thing that hasn't
changed is the prime minister um and
he walked past these events he attended
these events he raised the glass at them
and he knew that they were happening and
and and i should make a ver this may
sound like a very um pedantic point but
the rules don't say anywhere about work
events an exemption for work events
they simply said no gatherings were
allowed and these were gatherings and he
was at them so he knew they happened and
indeed you can see throughout sue grey's
report that and quite frequently she
refers to
the the obvious fact that a lot of the
people who are attending these events
knew that they were breaking the rules
they knew that these gatherings were
breaking the rules that's why they had
to say i think we've got away with it
and you know the stories about vomit on
the carpet and um red wine stains up the
wall and the cleaners having to clean
this up
the most
i think the most pernicious bit about um
the way that
the cleaners and the security staff were
treated is these will be the people on
the lowest salaries in danny street
these will be the people who did abide
by the rules
and and that's precisely the problem
that there were there is a set of people
in downey street and they're all still
there or nearly all of them are still
there
who simply believe that the rules don't
apply to them there's one set of rules
for everybody else in it and there's one
set of rules for them and it even
existed within downing it street itself
so all the special advisers and the
senior people were able to carry on as
they wanted um but
when when the cleaners and the um
security staff said look this is just
not right you're not abiding by the
rules uh they were you know they were
told where to get off that's it's just
morally indefensible i think yeah the
prime minister has addressed that we're
told by steve barclay and he is
apologizing personally to all of those
involved let me ask you let me move on
because no but sorry but he isn't sorry
kay well he says that he is
well he he may sort of do that apology
that sort of he did in the house of
commons yesterday but it actually
amounts to excuse after excuse after
excuse he doesn't believe he did
anything wrong or that anybody else did
he's blind to his own failings
he says we're told that he has
apologized to some staff personally and
he will apologize to more staff today
when they come on to their shift pattern
so you know we have to accept that that
is is what the prime minister has said
and that's what he has done and will be
doing um you're the chair of the house
of commons uh committee on standards
you've recruit
recused there you go yourself you're
having difficulty this morning with
words okay
it wouldn't be you couldn't say
yeah it would appear so but you've
recused yourself from um that
investigation but procedurally you will
know what happened so talk us through
the investigation what happens
uh so the i i
also chair the privileges committee
which has seven members on it it's four
conservative members two labor and one
smp
um the committee will have to decide
whether the prime minister has lied to
parliament has misled parliament instead
it's not whether he has deliberately
it's whether he has knowingly misled
parliament it's an important difference
because if you think of admiral nelson
um you know who put his blood his spy
glass up to his blind eye um and said
what ships i see no ships he was lying
he was knowingly lying um and i think
that that may be the conclusion that the
privileges committee comes to but i'm
not sitting on it um as you say i've
recused myself
and what the committee will have to do
is we'll have to decide what evidence to
gather whether to call people in to give
evidence they could if they wanted to um
ask some of the cleaners and the
security staff for their evidence could
our other members of staff working
downing street for their evidence
could require all the email exchanges
about uh following on from when the
prime minister spoke to the parliament
the first time about the issue and to
see what um and minutes of meetings that
were held to discuss um all of this um
and at some point no doubt they would
ask the prime minister to give evidence
either in in person or in writing um and
then they publish a report which then
goes to the house of commons
it should take i would guess
i'm i'm really guessing here but
when the standards committee had to do a
uh review a case that had been sent to
us uh about the prime minister's holiday
mystique a couple of years ago
uh from the moment that we got the
memorandum when the investigation had
already been done to completing it took
four months wow
so it'll be a while yeah if the
committee finds that um he did mislead
parliament he doesn't have to resign
though does he
no well if the committee it depends what
the committee recommends the committee
could recommend that
um he be suspended from the house
for a day or for ten days if it's for
ten days or more um and the house agrees
to that suspension then he could face a
a recall election in his own
constituency of 10 of his voters think
um that there should be a by-election um
so all sorts of things are possible and
and i can't entirely prejudge it because
i'm not going to be on the committee um
because i mean i i believe that the
prime minister has lied i think he's
lied repeatedly he's done so knowingly
uh sometimes he deliberately chose not
to know the facts he didn't investigate
enough the facts enough but he was
actually at the gatherings
so he knew that they had happened but he
told parliament that they hadn't okay
well he said that he thought they were
work events and that will take attacks
a few moments ago so we won't go back to
that what we will do though is talk
about if there's nothing to force boris
johnson johnson to quit
then what's the point of the
investigation
well they can force him to quit
if if he's i i'm sure i'm absolutely
certain that if the
privileges committee decides that the
prime minister has misled parliament
i i uh and sends a report to the house
for that effect uh boris johnson may
still try to cling on but i would have
thought that at that point every
self-respecting member of the house of
commons would vote for whatever
suspension is recommended by the
committee and if he's suspended from the
house he's out
that's it yeah but you need you need
conservative mps to vote for that don't
you
well
at every stage look there are four
conservative members on the privileges
committee and i respect them i have
absolutely no questions about them one
what they will all want to do a very
proper job i i know them individually
alberto um
bernard uh andy and laura and i'm sure
that they will do a very very thorough
job alongside whichever labour mp
replaces me and alan doran's and if that
committee comes to a conclusion which
has a conservative majority on it if it
comes to a conclusion that the prime
minister has lied to parliament
i'm absolutely certain that the
parliament that the prime minister will
leave office and probably leave
parliament
but it's down to at the end of the day
it's down to those tory back benches
that we often talk about isn't it well
in the first place it's down to the
committee yes look there's a big if at
the beginning of all of this yes no i
accept that and normally when you say to
me uh mr bryant if such and such were
going to happen what would you say and
then i normally say well i don't i'll
say hypothetical questions so um i throw
it back to you i'm this is hypothetical
if but but
nonetheless hypothetically if the
committee decides that he has mislead
people and misled parliament then i
think he'd be gone but more importantly
i suppose um
i think there's quite a lot of people in
the labour party who have now decided
that um actually
um for the labor party and for the next
general election let's keep boris
johnson
um
i think a lot of voters in the country
have made their mind up about the
conservative conservative party that
keeps boris johnson um you know the
culprit and the liar as their leader
and and indeed two conservatives i
bumped into in the left yesterday on the
way to a vote they they said to me look
we've lost the last the next general
election because tory collins won't act
against him even though they've seen it
flames of fight star
so but the downside is it's bad for
britain because we've got two major
crises going on ukraine and the cost of
living crisis and the prime minister
isn't able to concentrate on either of
them properly because this is going to
go on and on and on and all of these
were unforced errors which stem from his
personality
they'll all happen again that mimicking
of my accent was a mile off by the way
i didn't know you had an accent okay
it's lovely to talk to you as always
we'll see you soon thank you
now a review into the deaths of arthur
labino hughes and starr hobson has
called for dedicated child protection
teams the report says that there is too
much ambiguity and inconsistency in the
current system which does not serve
children or their families our home
affairs editor jason farrell reports
the report into the killing of star
hobson and arthur lobinjo hughes is a
depressing catalogue of failings with
the cases mirroring each other arthur
was killed by his stepmother emma tustin
his father thomas hughes was jailed for
manslaughter here on the day he died
arthur was barely able to walk the
report says too often social workers in
solihull relied on his father's
perspective they didn't discuss concerns
about his bruising with other agencies
it was the same with star simply not
putting the pieces together there was a
sort of inability to really know what
was happening and to join the dots if
you like and that's why we're proposing
the establishment in every area
specialist multi-agency
child protection units teams which will
bring
people from all the relevant disciplines
and agencies together working as one
team star was killed by her mother's
lover savannah brockhill her mother
frankie smith was also found guilty of
causing or allowing her death
star's favorite playmate her aunt alicia
made one of five referrals to social
services i'm coming for you
but this report says that in bradford
the high turnover of social workers was
exceptional and despite star's history
the person who made the home visit in
the month star was killed had no
previous knowledge of the family and
left the service the following week with
the assessment incomplete
i know social workers do have a lot of
cases and you know and it's hard and but
it's like if you are going to that job
it's like the social workers that i
dealt with to do with star it seemed to
me like they weren't really that
bothered
the report makes clear that calls for a
joined up approach have been made for
decades and arthur's cousin bernie dixon
is skeptical the whole system needs an
overhaul if they're suspected that
there's abuse i believe they should have
the power to remove that child
the rspca can remove a dog
but the social services can't remove a
child without
uh official documentation and i think
that needs to be looked at for emergency
purposes
this garden has been made in arthur's
memory
the star of the family celebrated her
birthday this month they focus on the
joy the toddler brought though they
can't escape the pain and long for a
system that will protect others from
suffering their grief jason farrell sky
news
well the independent chair of the
bradford partnership janice hawkes said
in a statement we know agencies let star
down and we must put things right the
publication of this thorough and
detailed independent review outlines
very clearly the opportunities that we
miss locally to better protect star we
have already put in place steps to
tackle this but we recognize that there
is still work to do and as a partnership
we are entirely committed to improving
the safety of children across bradford
right let's talk about the sue grey
report should we with that will walden
former press secretary to boris johnson
um hi will good to talk to you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning um your reaction to the report
yeah morning kay um
look
honestly i feel pretty depressed this
morning it's a sad day i you know i'm
joining you from athens where i'm
working this morning i flew in last
night and i had breakfast an hour ago
overlooking the acropolis this is where
democracy was born and the uk
prides itself on exporting democracy
around the world but i i just think it's
a bad day for democracy i think the
detail of this report is absolutely
appalling the partying people vomiting
on the walls you know there was even a
fracar some sort of fight at the height
of lockdown and this is at the heart of
the government of our country and i
think you know brutally speaking it it's
a bit of a it's a bit of a frat party
and i think it's bad enough happening
inside number 10 outside of the pandemic
let alone during it and i think
ultimately the prime minister has to
bear responsibility for that
and look when this first broke i said to
you at the very beginning of this that
boris sets the tone you know he loves to
be loved he loves to run a relaxed show
and unfortunately i think that this is
the result and i i'll give you one
example um martin reynolds who your
viewers will probably know now party
marty he's the guy that we now
understand sent the email that said oh i
think we've gotten away with it boris's
principal private secretary i know marty
and he's a lovely guy he's very very
capable but you have to ask why was he
enabling all this to happen he's the
prime minister's office gatekeeper he's
not some detached civil servant this guy
was hand-picked by boris at the time
plucked from an ambassadorial job in
libya they'd worked together at the
foreign office the idea that this was
all happening in some parallel universe
seems to me nonsense and i think
overridingly what worried me yesterday
is that you know boris reiterated that
he took personal responsibility that he
was humbled and he was sorry and in a
sense you know
he absolutely is
but what worried me was that every
opportunity he seemed to minimize that
he emphasized how brief his visits to
the parties were he defended his own
actions and what was extraordinary is he
said when it came to thanking staff at a
gathering which someone was fighting for
and therefore was illegal he didn't
think he'd done anything wrong and
actually he'd do it again and i think
what worries me about that is that it
makes the whole apology seem somewhat
irrelevant like he's some sort of
toddler he's been forced into an apology
he gets caught and he runs off
protesting the unfairness of it all and
where i would disagree with say chris
bryant who you had on a few minutes ago
is that i know i've known boris for a
long time he will be genuinely shocked
and sorry about the rudeness towards
cleaning and security staff so what
steve barkley says is is absolutely true
that's not his bag at all he would have
been genuinely appalled but i think
there's a problem here i think the rest
of it unlike a lot of people he doesn't
see this as the big deal that people are
making out and i think the question we
have to ask ourselves is is why he
thinks that
do you think he knew what was going on
no you're not
you know i i don't think there's
anything
deliberate here i mean i think you'd
have to be fairly blind not to notice
you know music pumping out in the in the
middle of the night or or people going
on longer or frankly
you know bottle strewn everywhere or
vomit on the walls on the other hand
he's running a country
during a pandemic and i think that's the
problem my feeling from reading the
report yesterday and you know listening
to the whistleblowers who were on the
bbc's panorama program the other night
is that downing street unlike the rest
of the country
was a bubble of normality there was no
sign whatsoever that any of the changes
that were made to the rest of the
country were made inside downing street
and i think this is clearly why the
partying the sort of wine time fridays
at 4pm didn't raise any eyebrows because
everything else was carrying on as
normal no restrictions no distancing in
office life so when the work day ended
life carried on as normal no one else
was having leading parties because no
one else was in a normal working
environment around the country and
honestly i cannot fathom why downing
street didn't put in best practice from
the off screens one rate corridors
essential staff only of course they're
responding to a pandemic but why did the
prime minister and his senior staff not
say
you know i want the 30 most senior
people in this building in every day
everyone else works remotely and
leadership is about setting
responsibility setting the tone and i
don't think boris did in that sense and
and yesterday what worried me was that
boris seemed to admit that a leaving
party was a normal and nice thing to do
it was leadership but in a world where
everybody at that time was cancelling
weddings funerals christenings not
visiting dying relatives not having a
leaving party seems to me a pretty basic
sacrifice to make and i think he
genuinely considered downing street to
be an exception to the rules he and
others didn't do anything wrong because
they were in a very specific very high
pressure situation but so were nhs
doctors saving lives
and that if they if they had partied
with people from outside number 10 they
would have known it was wrong but within
the building they were all working
together
so therefore the rules weren't the same
and i think he probably genuinely
believes that and hence those who think
otherwise are political opportunists or
they're just being like massively over
the top so when it comes to resignation
why would he consider resigning when he
doesn't really think that he's done
anything fundamentally wrong
well we're out of time eloquently put as
always great to talk to you thank you
very much thanks kate take care
you too
still to come on the program more
reaction to the party gate reporters
dining streets chief of staff tells this
program boris johnson is apologizing to
staff who suffered abuse in the wake of
the lockdown gatherings
[Music]